hey guys this is Dennis the founder
think here and I'm David Griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of HBO's True
detective episode for who goes there
now this this episode was crazy this
mean the thing that everyone's talking
about
is this last six minutes shot long one
one long take yeah I have to
congratulate the director cary fukunaga
that's how you pronounce his name
the writer NIC pizzolatto
yeah and the the Scimitar gopher Adam
arkhipov who also had shot animal
kingdom mm-hmm
that was fantastic yeah absolutely I
don't think we've ever seen anything
like that on television before no that
that was that whole sequence was pretty
incredible I mean he was basically
creating us a little mini riot in this I
mean every for everything to have to go
right with the extras and how many
moving pieces were the cars and they
pulled it off I mean it's just the
timing alone on that's crazy yeah six
minute continuous break yeah I had read
they had to do it about seven times to
get it right wasn't bad actually some
now for for that yeah six minutes yeah
it was fantastic yeah it's usually
something you normally see in movies
because movies has them have the budget
and the time to do it but obviously you
know HBO is one of those things that
kind of kind of blurs that line between
you know movies and television you know
it's it's so cinematic and it's you know
they've they've got you know they got
into Conahan Woody Harrelson who are you
know big movie stars but they're also
you know I'm Woody Harrelson was a TV
star yeah and yeah and also it was a
scene I'm not seeing there's multiple
scenes over six minutes it was just one
take that it wasn't done for just fluff
it wasn't just done for show it wasn't
like cool look at this cool take or
whatever what it was done for was the
tension that you felt with McConaughey's
character going into that whole like
robbery and then the whole like
everything going crazy which is
difficult to do because in the back of
your mind you know he lives because you
see him yeah Dec a decade or more
later you know telling his story but
it's still such a tense scene like I
mean I was tense during that whole
sequence they did such a good job making
you kind of fear for the guy's life like
maybe he might not get out of this even
though we know that he's alive in the
present day yeah that's hard to pull off
it is it is and yeah and in the part of
that reason was because of the
continuous take you're following him
around everywhere and you're seeing all
kind of the craziness that starts to
happen around him and and how you're
like worried oh how is he gonna get out
of this and you see all the danger
dangerous elements popping up left and
right from his vantage point I mean this
episode and I guess I heard some of the
creator's saying that the first few
episodes we saw were more about hearts
character Woody Harrelson and now we're
getting more into coal and this was a
very cold centric episode I mean we we
don't know who this guy is I mean he's
almost like he's a darker version maybe
like a James Bond not as charismatic of
course not in his you know smooth and
slick with the ladies but I mean he does
some dark stuff him he does all those
drugs and I'm assuming he hasn't done in
a long time he was you know putting the
stuff in his arm to make his arm look
marked up and like he'd been using for a
while I mean he did all this stuff just
to blend in but he was still coherent
and did his job well I mean he's he's a
badass I mean in this episode it's not
only that another dark side to him is
he's taking an advantage of the
situation with with heart yeah with
Woody Harrelson's character his marriage
has fallen apart because Lisa played by
Alexandra Daddario is you know got
pissed because of what he did in the
previous episode and so she rats him out
to his wife and now his whole family
life is blown up and Cole doesn't really
care about that he's like yeah he
doesn't really care and he takes
advantage of kind of the horrible
position that hearts in and kind of
convinces him there you can do this
yeah it's defined off it exactly and he
manipulates him in that way and he's he
met up with a hearts wife Maggie yeah
who pisses him off yeah and he has no
problem telling her oh yeah she's fine
you know like you guys are you yeah but
he's like oh you guys will be back
together in two months yeah oh yeah
cause he kept saying is like is that
your readers it's how what you think is
again
to me five and you can see in his eyes
he's just like it was like a little you
know well you know his character like
he's not hopeful about love and romance
and for him he'd be like guys were
screwed but yeah he's just telling him
so you can go on this mission and I like
that would he use I'm assuming he in
heart
sorry no coal and heart aren't friends
anymore what here's his character didn't
talk about this story off the books
I mean grant he's soul detective so I
guess he couldn't incriminate himself by
that but I mean he kind of beat around
the bush he was even interviewed by
those two detectives in the present day
I think they're both not talking about
what happened off the but he was saying
he took some time to go visit his dad
yeah go visit his sick dad he still has
a bond to get some loyalty back yeah
even though they're not friends anymore
and I'm sure there was something bad
that happened right he didn't rat him
out yeah there's something they have and
we haven't seen it yet right hasn't
happened yet but I'm sure we're gonna
see it coming soon and I love even
though this guy's not I love the
character I don't know his name the guy
in there and the prison they keep
interviewing oh he's great he's I love
him just I feel like suppose I remind it
so I can hear what he that accent is so
thick
I'm already blue do you know and but I
love that we're getting more about him
he just like a crazy dude I'm assuming
it's a guy in the gas mask we haven't oh
yeah actually Sam you know I mean I'll
have to wait for that seem to happen but
I like that like this guy's crazy son
but like devil-worshiping places with a
sacrifice babies and in the guys like
look I didn't argue with him he was a
big dude so I didn't talk bad about him
this Reggie LeDoux guy seems crazy like
he said makani's quicker said there's a
monster at the end of this hasn't any
darks there's a monster at the end
that's I'm assuming LeDoux is that
monster so and I'm glad you brought up
that prison scene because you had also
heart kind of taken jab at Cole yeah
when he's like when that prisoner guy is
talking about yeah you know you know
it's like crazy like he's saying all
this crazy stuff and blah blah blah but
he was bigger than me and I'm saying and
hearts like imagine that like I'm having
to listen to the ratings of a madman all
the time he's just looking right at Cole
the other guy that prison I felt bad for
was at the end he's like do you think I
had something to do like
because I told her do about that that's
why my girl's dead and he's like well
maybe yeah well I mean that's that's in
Cole's name right cuz he was like well
we'll screw him right who cares like he
messed up we all know he didn't do that
on purpose
Oh accident yes it probably did lead
through her death he's a criminal but
he's not like psychotic he's just look
yeah you need to do that
you know genuinely did care about her
yeah he was whatever twisted way I'm
sure you know but
and that's why hearts like you couldn't
just lie to a morgue yeah you know yeah
you scared of them so so yeah it's it's
good this this is a great episode of
television I think just things with a
show like this it's hard so I came of
Thrones it's almost like in watching a
big eight hour movie but this was a very
good self-contained episode it was very
self-contained great job for me it ranks
up there in the episodes of televisions
that I've seen oh yeah he's like in the
history you know with with the I think
like it was a Blackwater of Thrones the
red wedding those two were are up there
for me some other episodes the finale of
the shield a lot of different you know I
can't name all of the ones there's you
know maybe some breaking bad episode the
wire
you know there's certain episodes but
like this ranks up there with so are you
guys loving the show as much as we are
and what are you guys thinking what do
you think of that six minute ending
sequence so you know you can post your
comments below on the website st.
CARICOM or on our youtube channel think
here a pro also comes out with us on
twitter about any other HBO shows you
might be checking out as the nice 15
minute Game of Thrones preview before
that yeah game with those coming back
April is almost here so unless say we
thought about that at think here oh I'm
at Griffin de and we have saw the
Facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think arrow fans make sure to like that
page and share our videos on Facebook
Twitter and any other social networks
thanks